after years of buildup Batman finally
got the band together in Justice League
to save the world from certain doom but
there are still a ton of questions about
how exactly they managed to do it so
hold on to your mother box because
here's a spoiler filled look at some of
the biggest unanswered questions in
Justice League what happened to the
mother box the plot of Justice League
revolves around the villainous
Steppenwolf assembling the mother box
and almost wiping out the whole world
luckily cyborg and Superman team up to
pull the box apart in the nick of time
and everyone goes away happy but what
happened to the mother box after that
considering it has the power to bend
time and space and destroy entire
planets you'd think the Justice League
would want to keep a really close eye on
it but for some reason the box is never
seen again and where it ended up is just
one big question we have about the
mother box the other one being what
about Darkseid in Batman vs Superman we
got a whole dream sequence teasing the
arrival of the ultimate big bad in the
DC extended universe Darkseid so it was
pretty weird that he was barely even
mentioned in Justice League especially
considering almost the entire movie is
about him
see Steppenwolf works for Darkseid and
the mother box is trying to turn earth
into a new version of the planet
apocalypse which is also where
parademons come from and presumably
where the boom tube teleportation
tornados lead to so this movie was
really all about Darkseid but when it
comes to the DC EU who is he what does
he want and when is he gonna show up on
screen those are all questions Justice
League asks but doesn't answer what's
the deal with cyborg and Batman vs
Superman and Justice League we learned
that cyborgs cyborg e'en bits were
created by the mother box which
basically overrode his damaged body from
apocalyptan technology both Aquaman and
Cyborg himself raised concerns that the
mother box may turn cyborg against the
Justice League but other than one stray
missile fired at Superman's face nothing
comes of it well nothing comes of it yet
but what happens when cyborg faces
Darkseid the master of
pocalypse does the Justice League have
an unwitting mole inside their group a
double agent infected with an alien
virus that's waiting to betray earth at
just the wrong time maybe before Batman
builds his special table and Justice
League mansion he should consider
exactly what kind of ticking time bomb
he's letting on the team where was Green
Lantern in maybe the movie's coolest
moment fans finally got to see the Green
Lantern Corps brought into the DC
extended universe in a flashback
sequence where they team up with the
Amazons Atlanteans old gods and regular
schmoes to take down Steppenwolf when he
first attacked earth thousands of years
ago one question though where the heck
was Green Lantern during the fight at
the end of the movie Green Lantern's are
basically the beat cops of the universe
and since Darkseid and the forces of
apocalypse are pretty much the single
biggest threat in that universe you'd
think an APB would be put out as soon as
that mother box starts shimmy and yet
there's no sign of any Green Lantern's
in the present day at all was he at a
cosmic donut shop hopefully the next
time the world is about to be destroyed
it'll bother to show up stand back and
peep the light show Green Lantern's got
Green Lantern wasn't the only no-show
though where was everyone else when
Steppenwolf attacked thousands of years
ago a massive Alliance came together to
stop him this time around though
a handful of weirdos and costumes are
the only people who bother to lift a
finger
so where was everyone else for no
apparent reason the Amazon suddenly
aren't allowed to leave their Island but
why weren't the Atlanteans there to help
the Justice League how about you know
the Russian army who had to be wondering
about what was going on at that reactor
site and what about other characters in
the DC extended universe like The
Suicide Squad remember them why not
simple a task force of the most
dangerous people on the planet it seems
really weird that nobody else on the
planet cared whether or not earth was
destroyed how do they explain Clarke's
return most of Justice League revolves
around how much the world needs Superman
and the team successful efforts to bring
him back to life but how is anyone going
to be able to spin Clark Kent's revival
without giving away the obvious fact
that he's Superman
Clark got an obituary and a funeral and
Batman vs Superman but now he's back in
his old house and walking the streets of
Metropolis like nothing ever happened
between that and Lois referring to
Superman as Clark right out in the open
it seems that they may have brought back
Superman only to kill his secret
identity in the process who is in the
Legion of Doom finally we just have to
ask who else is going to be in Lex
Luthor's Legion of Doom so far in the
end credits scene we have Lex and
Deathstroke but if the Superfriends
cartoon is any indication we can expect
to see more villains in the future the
Joker of course has already shown up in
Suicide Squad but other bad guys like
Black Manta Captain Cold
and cheetah have yet to make their
debuts in the DC extended universe
frankly we don't care who is on the team
as long as Lex trades in that yacht for
a headquarters it looks like Darth
Vader's helmet and rests at the bottom
of a swamp give the fans what they want
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our YouTube channel
plus check out all this cool stuff we
know you'll love to
[Music]